hello welcome back to 8701
um in this lecture this little video
we're going to look at reactions and how
they relate
to cross sections so we start
um or continue the discussion um of
how we can relate proper experimentally
measured
determined properties to the forces
involved the last lecture we looked at
decay rates and the width of unstable
particles
this time we want to look at the
reaction rates expressed as
cross-sections and we can start
doing this um by looking at this
simplified picture
so the reaction rate is related or equal
to
the rate of the beam so how many
particles per second
are available for the interactions times
the number density of the particle in a
target
so you have your target here and clearly
the number of
uh reactions depend on how dense your
target is
uh the thickness so you go along
how you know the thicker the thicker the
material the target is the more likely
is for reactions to occur
and then by the actual physics by the
likelihood of a collision to occur
and this likelihood is called a section
and we can think about this cross
section
as a geometrical area
all right so let's look at this a little
bit more
again we stay with a very classical
model a model in which we have two
billiard balls
a light one a small one is radius r1 and
a
larger one with the radius r2 clearly
a collision happens occurs when
the impact parameter b
here between those two billiard balls
balls is smaller than
the sum of the radius okay
so now we can analyze this reaction a
little bit more and look at angular
distributions we find that this cross
section
differential distribution is given
as a function of sine theta we can
also express this using the azimuth or
as a solid angle here the remainder is a
solid angle
theta is equal to sine theta
e theta d phi
all right so for this
specific problem here we talk about an
isotropic
isotropic reaction because
by definition the
cross section per solid angle is
independent
of uh theta and phi
uh the matting between theta sine theta
and theta
is not trivial that's why you see this
shape of the distribution
um yeah
but the the sigma the cosine theta
is fed if you look at this as a function
of cosine
all right so this is just a classical
picture what we're going to do later in
the class
is using quantum field theory or
feynman rules in order to calculate
cross-sections also decay rates
um but you know this classical picture
is really something i would like you to
keep in mind
um the idea of the likelihood of the
collision to occur
is in units of an area and can be seen
as a geometrical cross section this kind
of conditions
a very nice picture to keep in mind and
it also helps
estimating orders of magnitude of rates
of collisions to occur